[Musique]
a sion la moitié sud dernière minute
dans les normales saisonnières glaçante
d'une scène de crime à plusieurs
victimes
tout a commencé quand des voisins ont
signalé des centaines de coups de feu
une fois sur place la police d'abus
guerre qui a découvert les corps de neuf
femmes dont plusieurs criblé de
nombreuses mal sidérant c'est ainsi que
les policiers pourtant expérimentés ont
décrit le carnage une mitrailleuses
télécommandées pour est a priori servi
dans la tuerie les enquêteurs
recherchent des témoins qui auraient fui
la scène de crime
qu'est qu'on détiendrait des
informations est priée d'appeler
immédiatement la police
[Musique]